Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie Dave Filoni and the Star Wars
people just teased Ahsoka Season 2,
The Mandalorian season 4, the Grogu movie
and confirmed that the Mortis Gods storyline from Ahsoka
Season one will continue to be a big plot point,
so we'll break it all down.
We've also got some more details since my last video
about what their actual plan is for
how everything is supposed
to fit together in the timeline.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course, I'll do episode videos for everything
they wind up releasing and videos for the movies
they wind up releasing now, too,
that we just heard about.
probably the biggest news since my last big Star Wars
video was Dave
Filoni confirming a lot of our Mortis Gods
theories from Ahsoka season one.
interesting, interesting, interesting.
he just released a new piece of the Ahsoka season
two concept art that he drew himself.
This is a Dave Filoni original.
He does this every once in a while
with the tokens, the being standing on the statues
of the mortal scars on the father's finger.
Where we last saw Bill in school in the season
one finale.
The funny thing about this is that after Dave
Filoni released this teaser, a bunch of people did
some fan art of someone pulling the finger
like pull my finger, but Mortis God, Star Wars style.
but the teaser confirms a couple of big things.
Ahsoka and Sabine will eventually make their way
to the mortis Gods statues.
The mortis gods will figure heavily into the season two
plot, at least, if not future plot beyond season two.
like it might also spill into what's happening
during the Thrawn movie
it will probably get to see a version
of the Mortis Gods in Live Action.
There are a couple of ways they could accomplish that.
Like either more flashbacks like Live Action
Clone Wars flashbacks with young Ahsoka
coming back, Hayden Christensen coming back
as the younger version of Anakin Skywalker.
and they could literally just do live action flashbacks
to the Mortis episodes from Clone Wars
like they did Clone Wars flashbacks during season one.
Same thing.
But just during the events of the Mortis episodes,
Or they could just
somehow do live Action mortis gods in present day.
Somehow Dave
Filoni would have to change some of the back story.
A little bit because they made it
seem like the son died during the events of the Clone
Wars Mortis episodes.
but either way, it is super weird and super cool
that Dave Filoni is bringing them into live
action is more than just a teaser that goes nowhere.
Like he did say, they would pay off this balance school
storyline with the mortgage gods.
Somehow.
back in the day when they were actually making
those Mortis episodes of Clone Wars, Dave
Filoni said it was actually George Lucas himself
who came up with the idea for Mortis guys.
He said that he wanted to introduce the force gods
into the Star Wars universe.
the story that George laid out for us
was something that I think that that we'd all
as Star Wars
fans, as lovers of mythology, wanted to delve into
for a very long time,
which was a much more intensive look at
the force and
force wielders and how that used
in this whole prophecy of the Chosen one.
And what does that mean for
the one who I was actually out of the room
for the first, I think 15 minutes, 20 minutes
of George's pitch of these force wielders.
And I remember coming back in the room
and the writers were
all just kind of wrapped up, like looking at George.
And they saw me come in the room and they looked at me
and they're like, You've got to hear this.
And George sat me down
and he started explaining to the gods,
and we are before.
They're much more powerful than any grenades.
And this one turns into a gargoyle. And this one.
GRIFFIN And he's saying all this stuff.
You're
like, Wow, this is pretty intense.
some of the weirdest ideas
that they came up with during the Clone Wars,
like the really cool lore, the back story,
just about the force in general.
The characters, George Lucas came up with that himself
and then basically brought it to the table
and was like, Look, we need to introduce this.
Let's find a way to do that No.
Dave Filoni is slowly
bringing all that stuff into live action.
the last we saw them
balance goal was standing on the father's
fist,
pointing at a beacon in the distance in the mountains.
it almost looked like it was a lava flow
erupting from a mountain.
but it was made to look as if the statue of the mortis
gods had been built by the ancient witch
kingdom of the death Mary at their height
before the fall of their empire in the father was meant
to be pointing at a special temple on that pretty
a planet that was a locus of power in the force.
Like some powerful place in the force.
That's probably the power
the balance school had been feeling calling to him
since they arrived at the planet.
The power that she not had not felt like.
I don't know what you're talking about.
When he kept telling her about it.
there have been a lot of theories
about who the villain of Ahsoka season two could be,
if not balance school himself like, logically,
it would be him.
But because Ray Stephenson passed away last year,
may he rest in peace.
Dave Filoni said they pay the storyline off,
but he didn't say whether or not
they would actually just straight up
recast the balance school role
or if they just gave that storyline to Shinhan
or just continue it through other characters.
but what they can actually do now
is they've already set this up.
Make Balance school responsible for freeing the son
from Mortis, which is the whole storyline.
During the original Mortis episodes.
It was the Son trying to trick them trick and Anakin
Skywalker into releasing him into the main galaxy.
during Ahsoka season two, they could reveal that
the son survived somehow, like his essence,
lived on after Aniket Obi Wan in Ahsoka left mortis
and he just stayed trapped there this whole time.
or in the same way
the force owl Mirai is an avatar of the daughter
like she contains some of the daughter's life force.
So a piece of the daughter lives on in her.
they could face the same situation with the Son,
where a piece of his essence
lives on in escapes
the more his realm because of balance.
School any that the son himself fully returns
or his spirit just possesses some random person
and because of that they can actually have Sam Witwer
Show Up is a live action version of The Son,
the first actual Star Wars character
that he played inside the actual Star Wars shows
after Star Killer because he was just a video game
character, was the son for the Mortis episodes.
he's talked a lot about this in the past,
but he did that before he ever did.
The voice of Darth Maul.
it started with this character called The Son of
Mortis, who they were like, You want to do Clone Wars?
I'm like, Yeah, sure.
And eventually I find out that you're like,
No, you're playing the dark side of the force.
named The Son,
and the audience is going to it's going to dawn on them
that this is actually the voice of the dark side,
if you didn't see any of my Ahsoka videos
or the Star Wars episodes from the other Disney
plus series that I did,
Sam Witwer has had stealth cameos
in almost every single Star Wars series so far,
But he's either always had his face covered
so you couldn't see that it was him or he was just
playing background voices so that you wouldn't know
that it was like he was using a different voice.
You wouldn't know it was him
unless you saw the credits.
people keep asking him, Why have you not shown up
in a Star Wars series Like you're a young person,
you're a good actor and you know you're star was like,
you're so into this Star Wars universe.
It's weird.
The ever showing up as a really big character on screen
where we can all see your face.
It's possible that Dave Filoni has just been saving him
for a much bigger role down the road,
maybe a live action version of The Son
just because if he showed up on The Mandalorian
playing a random bounty hunter
or one of the other Star Wars series, Ibi way harder
for him to then come back is a much bigger character.
Like The Son and the Son is a way bigger,
way more important character than some of the other
random characters that could show up as A lot of people
also asking about Star Killer, too.
He's talked about that showing up
as live action starkiller.
they're couple problems with that I'll talk about in
some of my other Ahsoka Star Wars videos in the future.
introducing Starkiller into the live action canon
in present day right now just creates a couple wrinkles
they need to explain.
It just makes things a little bit more complicated.
But it's not completely out
of the realm of possibilities
now people will be like,
No, no, no, we don't want the Son.
We want starkiller to show up in live action.
but if you think about it this way,
they can also use the Son as a movie level villain.
If things pan out with the Mandalorian Grogu
who movie in the Thrawn movie.
Reportedly, Lucasfilm is planning on doing a trilogy
of movies in this Mandalorian part of the timeline.
If the Grogu movie does well,
then they'll greenlight that third movie.
Would.
They would probably do though, because they're already
planning on doing the Thrawn movie no matter what.
So there's already two movies is the Grogu
movie does well.
They'll greenlight the third movie
and change the ending that they had planned originally
for the Thrawn movie and make it more of an Empire
Strikes Back kind of downer ending cliffhanger.
Right now it seems like the only really powerful force
wielding villains
that are going to be in those upcoming movies
will either be Zenyatta.
And she's not that powerful yet you know,
kind of putting her in a redemption arc anyway.
would be the knight sisters
like mother clothe though her two sisters
and the other undead knight sisters
that they plan on raising For sure.
They will be villains
in the upcoming series and movies,
But it just seems that they'll introduce
some other big force wielding villain.
And it seems like the mortis gods are a huge part
of the Knight Sisters history
with the ancient Witch Kingdom of Death.
they just make it seem like their race worshiped
the mortis gods to their ruin.
And it might have had something to do with the Son.
There's this big back story
that the father told Anakin during the Mortis episodes
About why he created the mortis
round this pocket dimension in the first place.
they were so powerful in the force, they implied
that they almost destroyed an entire galaxy.
They could just say that that galaxy they almost
destroyed happened to be the other polarity, a galaxy.
And that's why everything looks like it's in ruin.
So we just make sense that they're teasing
all this Mortis Gods storyline with balance skull
trying to find the mortis.
Gods find their power that it has something
to do with the back story of the ancient witch
kingdom of the death Mary in the Knight's sisters.
So then why wouldn't you bring back the Son
or the essence of the Son, or a version of the Son?
As one of the big villains of Ahsoka season two?
doing Sam Witwer is a live action
version of the Son would also be
a way around having to recast the balance school role.
Like if you're not going to be able to use him
all season, you need another villain.
It just makes sense to use another character.
That other character could be a version of the Son.
Because I don't think that Thrawn
is going to be the main villain of Ahsoka Season two.
I think she's going to be stuck in the pretty
a galaxy for most of the season.
might make it back to the main galaxy
by the end of Ahsoka season two.
But it wouldn't be to like the very end of the season.
Let me know in the comments.
What do you want them to do
for the villain of Ahsoka Season two?
Do you want them to recast balance school or do you
want them to just use a live action version of the Son?
Introducing live Action.
Son would also be a reason to bring back
Hayden Christensen in present day two
because he's kind of taken over the role
the mortise scars served, creating
balance in the force
the way that he exists right now in present day.
that was what the father told to him during the Mortis
episodes.
You are destined to replace us essentially.
He's basically doing what they used to do,
but on a more cosmic scale.
That's why we haven't seen him around so much,
because he's been busy balancing
the entire universe in the force some other details
we just got about the Mandalorian season four
and what's happening with the other stuff, too.
Is it apparently The Mandalorian Season
four about ready to film?
supposedly it might only be six episodes long.
and what would have been the final
two episodes might be turned into the
theatrical Grogu movie with a much bigger budget
Either way, the Grogu
movie is supposed to come out in 2026, then
Ahsoka season two comes out, then the Thrawn movie,
and if things go well, that next Mando versus movie,
like the third movie, maybe another season of Ahsoka or
The Mandalorian, somewhere in between the Thrawn movie
in the third movie, if it does wind up happening.
But either way,
it does seem like The Mandalorian season four will be
like the next Mando versus thing to actually happen.
And it will come before the Mandalorian Grogu
who movie but.
You can see they basically prioritize
all the Mandalorian, the Grogu's stuff that's happening
right now in the timeline before any of the other
movies, during other parts of the timeline,
doing the mando versus first
gives them time to get the new Jedi Order movie going.
They're completely rewriting the script on that.
So it's going to take a couple of years
before it comes out and doing all the mando
grogu movies first, like even the Thrawn movie
gives them time to wrap up Grogu storyline
in this part of the timeline if they want to.
then use an older version of Grogu who is like the main
character of Star Wars episodes X, XI and XII.
Whatever those wind up
being further forward in the timeline
in apparently the Rey New Jedi Order
movie is not meant to be Star Wars Episode X.
It's like something completely different off by itself.
We'll probably get some more teasers pretty soon.
There are a couple other live action
Star Wars series that are happening this year.
Of course, though, do videos for all that stuff?
click.
Here to learn about the really cool
Callixtus Easter eggs during Ahsoka season 1.
There's a really cool connection
and click here for my Deadpool 3 teaser trailer.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!